question would you give up monogamy for
a man
give up monster monogamy what is that
like he He Cheats
for a guy that you like for the right
yeah I I I'm waiting for me yeah I know
I don't think I can trust that guy again
no I would just I'm too jealous I'll
kill people are you monogamous now
yes I am yeah so in a way it's like in a
way aren't you not monogamous now
like a situation chip it's not
monogamous like usually the girl is
monogamous but the guy isn't
so it's fine no it's fine so there's
girlfriends I had to make this I had to
have this like thought too but it's like
if you've ever been in a situationship
in a way you're sharing a guy
she's really thinking right now yeah but
I'm I'm not in I wouldn't be in a like
committed relationship with someone and
it's like yeah it's us and
um no
even if I wanted to like I don't like I
don't judge other people who do maybe I
would like to want to but I'm telling
you like someone would die I I think I
think most girls would for the right guy
except I'm not saying about me they
might go crazy okay here's the thing
about me I am a little bit oblivious
because I'm very much in my I always say
I've never been cheated of not that I
know of maybe I'm so oblivious like I
would not check a man's phone I mean he
if he did cheat and he'd be up so dumb
for me he would be so dumb for me to
find like I don't check a man's phone or
like okay
yeah if I did find out then find
something on him with someone else I
honestly I don't think I would accept it
I would like to be like why like why did
you do that because man like to [__]
yeah but I
will do that four days straight I would
I don't know why most women say no like
why wouldn't you I had one friends he
was like really men like to [__] new
girls
like multiple you know but if you don't
want them you know I I tell you I coach
a lot of men I coach a lot of men
the whole thing of meeting a new woman
and no no okay I I have a question do
you think most men if they're in like
Tiger Woods position because I actually
no I used to I used to think like you I
used to think oh they wouldn't have like
like I know these guys that would never
cheat but it's like most of those guys
aren't in the position where women are
chasing them down and hunting them down
I don't know I've seen those guys and
some of them don't yeah
I've literally seen those guys I've hung
out with those guys I've got a lot of
male friends and they I mean there are
exceptions but I just don't but then I
wouldn't go out with somebody like in
time that's why I wouldn't go out with a
footballer even if I could I mean when I
was younger I could but I wouldn't I why
would you want to go out with a guy who
does have women throwing themselves on
him all the time like what she said
about pre-selection but then I was gonna
say now like if the guy high value
whatever whatever your kept you don't
have to worry about anything you can
just play football all day and then come
home yeah do four days straight yeah now
and then on on the fifth day he's with
Becky from The Local Schools no we're
done what is it that no Becky with a
good hair really it sounds like a pretty
good life yeah
you're 40. you're 42 you have a dog and
now you get you get to just be a
stay-at-home wife just made me think no
just once a week it's good luck I'm
gonna have to get the police up here
again
definitely you're not gonna have to get
the footage but no no that's like that's
what I'm saying like my no okay
I would be too jealous I would I am way
too
probably arrogant to no
if you listen to what you had to say
remember what you said before about
listening yeah but if he needs new
that is the other thing like
I can't that even if I could get over it
emotionally which I don't think I could
I could not get over the germs and the
the disgustingness of sleeping around I
cannot tell you yeah but it's so
interesting because in a way like you
you had a cat your hat I mean you talked
about a casual relationship so
essentially most women have like
essentially you are you're getting over
that now no but if I've made the
commitment yeah but no that would be
different for me
what's the difference
um
foreign
would be in yeah there's a commitment
I've given my word you've given your
word and we're going to be exclusive
and then if you go and do that behind my
back no
okay I know I would want to know why no
I I under what do you mean this is like
a lack of understanding of guys dude 100
yeah I mean I think even good guys would
have a hard time if they're in a
position where women are throwing at
themselves at them
come on I would
I wouldn't have got you wouldn't throw
it themselves at him all the time I
wouldn't but the guy you're with
probably is that's my point it's like
the guy you're with he said he's
athletic he said he's got a good job you
said he's tall like he probably is in a
position where women are throwing
themselves at him that's like three out
of five things that you wouldn't yeah
like that's all right then I'll forget
about him I love him like no which is
gone man like no you got me thinking no
no I wouldn't I I I'll probably actually
you're right I'll ask him about that I
don't know
I don't know I think
I have so many questions
I had a guy point this out to me once
like that like women will say they won't
accept like non-monogamy yet most women
have been in a situationship at some
point which is non-monogamy so it's kind
of like a double-edged but I have
friends that their their husband just
cheated on them a few times and they're
still living together yeah I know a lot
of girls yeah I mean think about it it's
like okay if you're if you're like 45
right 50 45 let's say 45 and you get
into a relationship with a guy or you've
been with a guy and you find out he
cheated and he pays for everything it's
like what so you're gonna leave what's
on the other side now you get to work
for the next 30 40 years
yeah but but yeah that's what I I think
my brain is like a matter I could not
get over that [__] like I am no yeah
maybe maybe you couldn't my brain
doesn't have that part where he could
accept that I couldn't but do you see
what I'm saying
you see you see what I'm saying though
but you're in a situationship now and so
in a way you are accepting it
you think about that
do you know what I'm saying because it's
it's just like it's a contradiction
because you're saying I could never
accept it but if you're in a
non-monogamous relationship I'm not in a
relationship it's a type of relationship
right situation it's a situation [__]
I'm not trying to shame you foreign
it's just interesting how I'll talk to
girls about this and they'll be like no
I would never I would never accept that
and then a lot of those gross same girls
are in situationships and if you're in a
situation
yeah I don't think I could I would like
to be one of those I don't think I
physically could do it
but it's again it's still a
contradiction because you are
you know
so you have it in you
you know no because I don't know
what about if you just looked the other
way and you know he might but no
I I would say
80 he isn't but then I don't know
um
I have reason to believe he isn't but I
don't know 100 he might be
you're just trust in it no it's not even
true
no it's not even trust it's just I'm
just looking at the reality and putting
yeah and
I don't think he would be but it could
be could be but if I did see it or if I
had evidence or if I did even think no
it probably is no I would I'm just
asking if he doesn't care about you he's
gonna tell you the truth
I I asked him kind of
four or five months in and he said he
wasn't
um
but I haven't asked him recently
oh but I know you say that the the
headache that you gave him was within
six months and then four or five months
yeah you asked him if you're sleeping
with anyone else so yeah maybe after I
gave him my headache
you said you were not in relationship
with no but she's saying I'm still in a
situationship but do you agree that
you're in a situation
I I am in a situation
do you know do you do you know it to be
true that he isn't sleeping with anyone
else I don't know 100 no okay
do you guys are trying to break up these
relations
we have a case studies
that Mandana is that yeah okay it's good
the point she's making I'm I get it and
I 100 like agree like
um yeah that's why I don't I don't judge
well I don't think women who stay with
them men are true I don't think oh my
God you should leave him I have I don't
you know what's interesting we had a guy
um who
um he talked about that
he would break up with girls because he
just felt like he couldn't stay faithful
to them like he just couldn't do it no
no and this is a dude that paid for
everything he like 100 would take care
of the bills and
um the
and he ended up like marrying this last
girl because she said she could accept
it and that girl on donut I mean she
ended up winning when you think about it
because she got the deed to the house
she got the uh well if that's your game
yeah I mean
I guess so you do have your own money I
guess that maybe that's what it doesn't
appeal to me that it doesn't mean
anything to be honest for him to pay for
everything well um
and then you can just buy new football
boots no I'd rather have it to myself it
depends what is important for for that
for that yeah for me it's more important
to have them to myself than having but
even even if it's just looks like a guy
you're really attracted to even if it's
height you know I mean most I mean
either way it most guys that you want
there aren't enough like more women want
them yeah you know it's usually not just
you yeah no 100 I say that Tim I was
like I bet audio
foreign